how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and
mcu and today we have some very
interesting news and it's about black
panther 2 and marvel's future plans for
the franchise now ever since the tragic
passing of chadwick boseman everybody's
been wondering what exactly is going to
happen with black panther moving forward
are they going to recast the role of
t'challa slash black panther are they
going to replace him are they going to
write black panther out of the mcu is
shuri going to become the new black
panther a lot of
questions that are really up in the air
right now but today it seems like we may
have some answers
including what marvel is thinking about
doing right now and the possible
inclusion of
namor in black panther 2. yesterday
grace randolph from beyond the trailer
stated that she heard from
a trusted source that they are making a
chadwick bozeman digital double
that's looking very lifelike the current
plan is that t'challa will die in a
battle at the beginning of the film
and shuri becomes the new black panther
she added to her report
also there is a version of the script
where t'challa and shuri's mother was
killed a long time ago
by the atlanteans thus raising the
stakes
versus namor we'll see if they stick
with that
so if this is legitimate and this is the
route that marvel studios decides to go
down it'll be very interesting to see
how it plays out
obviously right now marvel studios is
put in a pretty tough position
chadwick boseman was insanely loved by
pretty much everybody and he was the
perfect black panther
and a lot of people don't want to see
him replaced as black panther but of
course they're going to continue the
franchise now marvel studios definitely
has the ability to use cgi to make a
very
lifelike cgi chadwick boseman and as
this report says they plan on having
t'challa die
in battle at the beginning of the movie
they most likely won't show this happen
it would be a little bit too much to
show his death on screen since he passed
away in real life
what's more than likely going to happen
is that they'll share a few scenes in
the very beginning with shuri and with
his mother
and okay it'll probably be a pretty
heartfelt scene and then his mother will
get news of his death
but we won't actually see it and then
according to this report
shuri who would be next in line would
become black panther
now thanks to the mcu book the wakanda
files which is canon we know that shuri
has figured out a way to recreate the
heart-shaped herb so
she would have a way to get the black
panther powers that come by eating the
heart-shaped herb therefore she can
become
a true black panther and she has become
black panther in the comics before as
well
now as far as the atlanteans and neymar
and this second script where t'challa
and shuri's mother gets killed a long
time ago by atlanteans is concerned it's
very interesting
you see in the comics t'challa and shuri
are actually only half brother and half
sister
t'chaka the former black panther and
king before
t'challa becomes black panther is the
father of t'challa and shuri but
raimonda is actually not t'challa's
biological mother it's his stepmother
but she is the biological mother to
shuri now the report says that there's a
version of a script that says t'challa
and cheri's mother was killed a long
time ago
but that doesn't really make too much
sense because we saw their mother in the
first black panther so perhaps what they
mean to say
is that it's actually going to be
t'challa's mother that died a very long
time ago to an atlantean or perhaps in
the mc raimonda isn't the biological
mother of shuri and shuri's mother died
a long time ago
either way it does open up atlantis the
atlanteans
and namor to enter black panther 2. and
before chadwick boseman passed away it
was pretty much all but confirmed that
namor was in fact going to be a pretty
big part of black panther 2. and
recently we've had some pretty big
reports that say atlantis and the
atlanteans are going to be in the
eternals movie
specifically the sinking of atlantis so
plans for neymar to appear in the mcu
have already begun
now if marvel's plans were to introduce
namor in black panther 2
obviously they have to switch those up
just a little bit now it's going to be
shuri as black panther that possibly
takes on namor and the atlanteans but as
far as retconning the story goes it
shouldn't be too hard as atlantis and
wakanda have a pretty big history with
each other
but according to this report from grace
randolph this is what marvel studios is
currently discussing
for black panther 2. if this is true
it's a very
interesting route to go so i want to
know what you think about this would you
be
okay with black panther dying in black
panther 2
off screen and then shuri become the new
black panther
be sure to let me know what you think in
the comments down below don't forget to
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all things relating to the mcu and for
my future giveaways please
like the video if you enjoyed it and for
live updates you can always follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof